We'll be looking at messaging and
document standards next.
But both of these rest on the data
standards we've just discussed.
To see that,
go to the URL in the instructor's notes,
it will take you to the HealthVault
Developer site to access a sample
of a CCD,
an XML formatted patient summary.
Find the Problems section and use it
to answer the questions that follow.
Note that the problems
are represented in three ways.
First, in easily human-readable text,
next in a table format that could
readily be viewed as part of a web page,
and third, the same problems are wrapped
in a considerable amount of
data standards nomenclature.
Each of these begins with an entry
type code and ends with /entry.
Study what's between these to
see how complex HL7 has become.